beneath the streets of Stockholm Sweden
is the world's longest art gallery a 68
Mile cavern of culture exhibiting over a
hundred and 50 artists it also happens
to be a metro system that carries nearly
a million riders a day turning the
morning commute into something truly
inspiring
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
in the Old English seaside town of
Margate there is a mysterious
underground cavern adorned with millions
of seashells its winding passages
stretch more than 70 feet and are
believed to have been constructed in the
early 1800s but no one knows who built
them or why
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
three and a quarter miles east of Key
Biscayne near Miami Florida is an
underwater eternal resting place for
ocean lovers the Neptune Memorial Reef
is an artificial man-made reef that
houses the remains of thousands of
people after cremation ashes are mixed
with cement to form features that become
part of the reef
the reefs design was inspired by the
underwater city Atlantis and includes
lion statues columns benches canopies
and podiums it takes up half an acre and
sits 40 feet under the surface of the
water the Neptune memorial reef serves a
dual purpose as a home to many
underwater creatures fulfilling its
mission of creating life after life
you
anytime I'm inside the cave
I feel I'm in a different time scale
above the ground is much faster the tree
grows and dies in like hundred years but
inside the caves it's millions of years
and it's timeless
[Music]
eleven miles north of Beirut hidden
inside a mountain lies the Jeita grotto
the pride of Lebanon and one of the most
majestic caves in the world when we say
ether cave everybody knows yet I gave
it's a very important cave because it's
the main water source of Beirut and area
near Beirut a small portion of the Jada
grotto is open to the public
the rest is accessible only to a select
few
including this billiard club founded in
1951 it's the oldest most respected
caving club in the Middle East this
particular bond was founded during the
explorations of Jada grotto the same
history of our club is the history of
Jada grotto every week this billiard
club gets together and girls caving in
the grotto when they explored they
travel by birch down a subterranean
Black Lake their mission is to discover
new caves map them photograph them and
ultimately protect them there's no doubt
that she thought crystal is really a
work of art simply because of its huge
scale and it's huge formations and those
formations aren't set in stone the cave
is very much alive all of this is still
under the roaming it's not a fossil gave
yet still living this cave in the last
65 years the Spiller Club has discovered
over 600 caves every weekend their work
goes on we can say that we had explored
all Jeita cave because it's two years or
one years we discovered new things so we
are still working inside Jetta and we
will not finish
[Music]
underneath the Turkish region of
Cappadocia a system of hidden tunnels
and caves when undiscovered for a
thousand years until one man decided to
renovate his home 18 stories below the
ground level and the Turkish region of
Cappadocia is the ancient hidden city
that include the city was rediscovered
in 1963 when a man knocked down a wall
in his basement and stumbled across a
hidden room this triggered an excavation
of the area to reveal the hidden city
that is a thousand years old and over
280 feet deep it is thought to have been
created during the Byzantine era around
1000 AD to protect the community from
wars and natural disasters it is made up
of a network of tunnels connecting what
would have been kitchens stables
churches wells and even schools the
Cappadocia region is known for
subterranean safe havens and it's
speculated that Dan and qu you may have
connected many of them the city likely
could have hidden 20,000 people
livestock and food supplies making it
the largest underground city in
Cappadocia
you
there's somebody driving into town the
first time you wouldn't think there was
a lot here because 95% of it is hiding
underground people drive in and go where
is the place I don't understand
cube appears from the aboriginal kippa
picky which means white man in a hall at
the moment upstairs
it is about 122 degrees Fahrenheit down
here we're sitting on about 71 72
degrees no air conditioner necessary
well right out in the middle of nowhere
it takes a day to drive here from
Adelaide I'd say there's about a
thousand underground dwellings and at
least 1500 people living on the ground
we've got five underground churches we
got underground motels there's some
amazing underground homes here many
bedrooms underground workshop
you name it underground we've pretty
well got it I bought mine dug out as a
fairly small two-bedroom dug out and
I've been extending it over the years
some other side blasted out when I could
get away with it the cops don't life is
blasting intent we don't do it anymore
back in the old days if somebody was
going to have a baby
we'd rock around there with a couple of
compressors on a weekend and some Jack
Amazon a couple of cartons of beer and
by the Sunday night we dug out of room
cemented the floor and wired it up and
there's your new baby's room honey even
though we're so far away geographically
from anywhere else but I know why but we
just loved the place to piss
[Music]
hidden 150 feet below Kansas City in a
270 million year old limestone deposit
more than 1600 people work in the
world's largest business labyrinth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you